USA Today Washington bureau chief Susan
page joins us now good morning Susan
hey good morning I just want to know you
know just getting your expert opinion on
these things when you hear about the
president not only wanting to reduce
troops but also making sure that we
resume talks with the Taliban is this
and will this likely lead to any actual
peace deal I think I think it's hard to
know but this is a the president's
effort to fulfill a promise he made
during the last campaign that 26 came
2016 campaign to end America's
participation or reduce America's
presence in what he called endless wars
now he's been trying to do that for some
time we remember he had he had we
learned three months ago that he had
planned a big event at Camp David with
the Taliban and the Afghan leadership
that fell through in the wake of some
violence in the region but he clearly
wants to get this restarted we want to
hear more from the Taliban about whether
they confirm that these talks are
serious and also from the Afghan
government on their view of this they
have previously insisted on a ceasefire
before it talks that hasn't happened yet
right I want to switch gears really
quickly here former Navy secretary
Richard Spencer had a lot to say slam
the president basically when he was
ousted in reference to the president's
involvement in the Navy SEAL that was
convicted of war crimes were you
surprised at all by Spencer's reaction
in some of the comments that he's made
man he used words like unprecedented and
shocking to describe the commander in
chief he said that President Robb didn't
understand what it was like to be in the
military these are words that Pentagon
leaders do not use about the president
the United States during normal times
this was this was a now stir that
reflects some of the tension behind the
scenes between the Pentagon and the
White House that we that's rarely
revealed this was really an insight into
something's going on this that's quite
unusual switching gears now Susan to the
eyes that will be watching the House
Judiciary Committee and it's hearing on
the impeachment inquiry what do we
expect to get out of this well we lot of
things to watch for you know by Sunday
that White House needs to say whether
the president
his lawyers will participate in those
Judiciary Committee hearings the House
Intelligence Committee is finishing up
its report on its impeachment
investigation we've got the first
hearing coming up Wednesday we'll be law
watching for the articles of impeachment
that we believe the Judiciary Committee
will drop you know this is moving so
fast we expect a vote by Christmas over
impeaching the president another
historic term in this really
unprecedented presidency we've been
watching for three years and just one
quick question on this Mick Mulvaney
John Bolton both absent weren't called
by really didn't make it to testify was
that a mistake on Democrats parts
well Democrats have been trying to
pursue getting testimony from people
like the Secretary of State in the
acting White House chief of staff the
White House has had a stone wall
strategy the Democrats have gone to
court they've won in some court cases
but court cases take a long time appeals
by the White House and the
administration to higher courts it's I
think the House Democrats just decided
this was not going to work they were not
going to be able to talk to these
officials in a timely fashion but they
definitely wanted to because they wanted
more first-hand testimony about exactly
what the president's whorl was in this
issue over Ukraine Susan I'm told we
have 30 seconds left quick question
about 2020 Mike Bloomberg does he stand
a chance
well he's got he's got a strategy which
is to not participate in the early
primaries and caucuses and instead to
come in on Super Tuesday maybe that'll
work he's got a lot of money behind him
but I got to say this is a strategy that
didn't work for president Rudy Giuliani
when he tried it or for president Jerry
Brown when he tried it back in 1976 so
we'll see fair Susan page thank you
thank you